so david
when it comes down to yourself how
similar is your story you're not in
california you're michigan
how similar or different is your story
from angela's
well we've got some we've got some
differences and at the heart we've got
some very uh
good similarities the difference is uh
you know she's got a liquor license
and in michigan those who would like to
open back up and do some things as soon
as they do try to do that they get their
liquor license
i'm not experiencing that i don't have
that threat hanging over me
uh she employs more people than i do i
bought this later in life when my kids
were raised and me and my wife
just paid it off and trying to do a
little pension pad here for ourselves
and it's her and i and and my son helps
out and then i got two cooks and a
waitress
uh we uh laid off two of them right away
back in march
back then you know they had the stimulus
package and they were getting the
uh extended benefits with the
unemployment amounts
and it that seemed to sustain everybody
probably more than it should have i
gotta say that
um but people come out and they
supported us we're more of a um a small
tight knit you know hey we only seen 40
people so we're on different spectrums
here a little bit
um but with the traffic flow we have in
the in the neighborhood we have
uh it's worked for us for 12 years and
to watch it slowly erode
uh over the course of the summer and you
know even at half capacity the customers
were supporting us with takeouts well
you know when the unemployment ran out
uh the stimulus monies ran out we get
into fall time
and we were doing okay and then we got
into the return of the school students
uh maybe halloween
a lot of contact surface contact things
there that i seen kind of would would it
would start exploding these numbers
and they come right back in the same
small segment of the economy
and said hey you're you know basically
you're to blame we got to shut you down
again
and you know out here we're different
because we don't have the sunlight and
the heat and the warmth
she's got perfect scenario out there
design outside with the sanitization
measures
uh i we don't even have that opportunity
to have them shut her down i don't
understand
um but um i want to show you
i want to show your video for the
audience to see and as well as angela
she hasn't seen it yet
because your videos is
you know it was prom impromptu you
weren't even ready for it it just kind
of happened i want to share this with
the audience because it's a
very interesting setting on what
happened with yours
somebody's telling the news and then all
of a sudden you walk up on them
and then this is what takes place
newschannel 3's tavares haywood joins us
live in portage
with the details on why the judge
said no javarius is everything okay
okay my government leaders have
abandoned me are you
are you the owner of four trillion
dollars of
stimulus money i gave it to who special
interest groups and campaign donors i'm
dave morris i own the place
so what's going on what's going on you
know what's going on tell me you tell me
hey we got a government
that has taken the stimulus money they
gave it to special campaign
donors they gave it to special interest
they abandoned me
and they had put me in a position where
i have to fight back
you could have given me money i'd gladly
walk away for 60 days and let this virus
settle down
i'm not going to do it alone okay are
you going to continue to violate the
state's orders and stay open
state order this isn't an order this is
a conspiracy this is a tyranny
what do you want to tell other
restaurant owners who wake up stand up
this is america be
free it's time to rise up gotcha get the
rides up shut it all down or don't shut
any of us down that's the only way to
get control of a virus
angela what do you think when you see
his reaction here in the interview
amen was a little different style of
passions we had there but
uh amen i mean here people were afraid
we're afraid you know
that we're going to get boycotted we're
afraid that people are going to think we
want to kill them because you know
you know we don't believe in covet or we
don't you know
i i it's i
commend you and i wish and i hope that
whatever we're doing
creates a revolt with the businesses
because
this is outrageous i mean
the courts the judge in the court get
this
found that not only were they in
violation
right and they they were overstepping
their power by shutting us down
but that 3.1 of
all cases of going out were
from outdoor dining and the majority of
those
were coming from fast food chain
restaurants i've got an in-n-out burger
that has 50 people in line every day as
i sit here shuttered
and that's what they were shutting us
down on you know that's what a judge
ruled was you know overstepping their
power
you know they've destroyed half the city
based on nothing it's i
i i love i love what you did i love it i
wish it would
be more contagious over here
we hope to get there okay that was very
uh
it was fortunate for me but i didn't i
didn't plan on knowing that because i
asked them not to come around that day
they weren't relaying my messages here
in michigan
uh i'm i'm just you know 25 30 minutes
from the
invisible border i call it where they
can go down to indiana and they can eat
and dine
and i've had too many customers tell me
the weather's getting cold they're going
down to the christmas shop they're
stopping for breakfast
and then they're coming back into
michigan after they have dinner and
doing the christmas shopping see
and that started to irritate me my local
media wouldn't say that
and i started talking what you just said
there about i seen a bus at my local
drive-thru national chain
and there were several people on it and
they were walking them down in the
aisles and no mask on them and they just
went through the drive-through and i'm
saying
hey come on man who's that guy in front
of me that gave him 75 cents and
quarters
nice guy behind me gets them they're
trying to convince us that there is no
surface contact this is a virus and i
refuse to accept the fact that
if there's they're trying to tell me a
little microorganism's gonna float
around the sky for 10 minutes
and it's you know wait for the nice guy
to come sucking in
well hey hey they're trying to tell me
that if you have a special permit
the virus won't get you because the
virus recognizes you have a permit
and see what that's what they're doing i
mean do they'd like to believe people
believe that this
this air stagnant you know i got a small
cafe there okay and i've got an
overly large hood system it's kind of a
uh a hinder it's on me because i get the
utility bills and when somebody opens my
front door
my swing door into my kitchen goes open
by four inches and all goes up the hood
system
and to tell me i've got a stagnant
airflow where it's just sitting in there
mingling
no way and if so i brought it to their
attention earlier in the week about the
uh cdc uh then i went on the newest
update since october
and september and they talk about
surface contact how long does the covet
19 stay on surface two hours up to a
couple days
so i still say we've got a lot of people
that are cross-contaminating in the
grocery stores in the department stores
and
um they're not washing their hands
before they put that you know what right
now as we speak
they put stricter rules in they've shut
down
playgrounds hair salons nail salons
listen uh parks zoos listen
tj maxx is packed with christmas
shoppers and so is the indoor mall the
indoor mall
that doesn't take a temperature doesn't
wear a glove doesn't have a mask
it's packed with people trying on
different clothes
and they're open right now as we speak
that's right i made a banner
a big red banner and it said if divided
we fall
closed them all now yeah it was
t-h-e-m-a-l-l
but when you read it fast it's closed
them all
so i put that in my on the front
on the fence and some people get it some
don't but my
you know my exactly what you're saying
is what i'm complaining about the
inconsistencies policy
and um uh i don't know let me kind of
share with the audience what the
restrictions they said in your state in
michigan
uh governor whitmer your governor
administration on sunday ordered high
schools and colleges
uh to stop in person classes close
restaurants to indoor dining and stop
organized sports in a bid to
curb michigan's uh spiking coronavirus
cases right
it started november 18th wednesday in
the last three weeks then continues
for restaurants and bars dining service
likely
will not be allowed to resume that with
the current set of restrictions expires
on december 20th
michigan department of health and human
services director robert gordon says
on the bottom a justin winslow who's the
president and ceo of the restaurant
association
he said the following says we firmly
believe there's a better approach
one followed by 45 other states that
doesn't use
blunt force closure of a single industry
to resolve a shared crisis
he pointed out that michigan restaurant
dining rooms will be closed for 118 days
in 2020 that's nearly four months by
december 20 the restaurant industry lost
eight billion dollars in sales
and laid off 75 percent of its workforce
for that time what has changed since
that day
when your video went viral on twitter
what's changed david what's happened to
you nothing that's just exactly
there all they did was extend it now
there's things changed for me personally
believe me
i didn't expect that go viral that was a
big surprise uh him being there and me
surprising him and he kind of spread to
me when i pulled in to drop off goods
there's a lot of things that's changed
in my personal life where all of a
sudden i'm able to kind of
uh uh encourage people to stand up in
the cafe
it's been tremendous change we've had so
much support so many people coming
uh and you know i i like to say we've
had on first part was kind of negative
for me because on a personal basis they
they
people like to attack you they think
that you're the only one but you're out
to kill society yeah
and um i've had death threats you know
it's when my when my grandchildren have
to read that it bothered me it hurt my
heart a little bit
and i asked my daughter just don't let
him read it because any time you're
going to stand up to something that you
then you know
that you've been pushed to the point and
you're true
in in in what you're doing not
everybody's going to like that okay
you can't ever be 100 popular but you
got to do it and we got to teach our
kids
we're doing this for our grandkids by
the way i don't want people to forget
this
i'm after my liberty i want it back i
want my freedoms back in this country
i want us to have the right to choose
and the people that abused me
uh verbally on the social sites uh it
was pretty easy just to say i don't pull
you into my cafe i don't go out and
twist the arm and they can't hear okay
and we have continued to defy they took
my license a couple days ago wow uh
you know where i was gonna go next that
was my next question for you so here's a
question for both of you
how concerned are you knowing both of
you are
in an industry where you angela on this
side you have a liquor license and you
you need licenses you need permits you
need certain
you need certain things to happen and
that's led by the local
politicians local whoever government
employees that may be
how concerned are you that if they
really wanted to push you around they
could
you know what well i'm sorry but my
response to that is i'm 59 years old
okay
i've struck i won't say i've struggled
but i've i've pulled myself up by the
bootstraps many times and i've worked
too hard for somebody to push me into
that corner
with no say so and drive me into
bankruptcy and then think i'm gonna go
away quietly and forget about me
i would do my best to raise the troops
in this country
we are due for this and i'm not gonna
fear this i keep thinking back to when
my father grandfathers and forefathers
fought for my freedoms and the older i
get the more important that becomes to
me for my grandchildren my
great-grandchildren
and i i we can't fear this and i that's
what i'm talking about this you can't
fear the concept
if we all come up together and i know
the problem we i know your problem and i
know our problem here i got friends that
own these
um like i say restaurants with liquor
license it's a little more difficult
uh they'll be the next step but somehow
we gotta bust the barriers and we can't
fear that we just can't um
[Music]